good evening and welcome to the 53rd
annual radio and television
correspondents association dinner
i hope you all enjoyed your meal
i'd like to begin tonight's program
thank you
good evening and welcome to the 53rd
annual radio and television
correspondents association dinner
i'd like to begin our program tonight by
asking you to please rise
and join me and the executive committee
in our traditional toast
mr president
we're drinking to you
you don't need to get up
to the president of the united states
and mrs clinton
to the men and women of the 105th
congress
thank you may be seated now
i now like to introduce our head table
guest
could you please hold your applause
until i've introduced everyone
beginning on your left my right
at the end larry janzik director of the
senate radio and television gallery
ken block msnbc
jenny trazano press secretary the vice
president
you can stand jenny
thanks
dan scanlon mutual nbc radio
christina martin press secretary to the
speaker
evelyn thomas cbs news
our speaker tonight norm mcdonald from
saturday night live
jim mills of fox news
congress congressman tom delay house
majority whip
keith plummer of reuters television
oh
i'm so sorry i apologize
and to the left of the first lady vic
ratner of abc news
and on this side beginning at the end
tina tate director of the house radio
and tv gallery
carol ann mears of nbc news
neil lattimore press secretary to the
first lady
dave mcconnell wtop radio
congressman thomas blighley chairman of
the house commerce committee
joe johns nbc news
mike mccurry the president's press
secretary
dan rather cbs news
senator don nichols senate majority whip
and brian naylor of npr
and and please join me in welcoming back
to our dinner this year the president of
the united states and mrs clinton
thank you
dan rather is here tonight to help this
association pay tribute to a former
colleague
joan shorenstein barone was a producer
for cbs news
after she died an award was created in
her memory
it honors excellence in washington-based
national affairs reporting here to
present the 10th annual barone award is
someone who worked with her dan rather
thank you
mr president
first lady
and thank you all of you for being here
tonight
i've been asked to present an award that
is named for a woman many of us we're
lucky enough to know and lucky enough to
miss
she left us 12 years ago
and yet it's hard to think of her as
gone
that's not only because of the
extraordinary job her father and her
late mother
her children and husband
have done in keeping her memory alive
joan's father walter shornstein and her
daughter sarah barone
are here tonight
it's also hard to think of joan as gone
because joan herself
was so strong a presence in our lives
she worked at the washington post and
came to cbs news as a researcher
she became one of the best producers
that face the nation ever had and later
did equally ex work as a producer for
the cbs evening news
perhaps because she began as a
researcher
she had a passion
for accuracy and facts
but she also
had a passion for fairness she never
allowed her passion for facts
to get in the way of her passion for
truth
when she died a number of us recalling
that she came from a well-to-do family
observed how remarkable it was that joan
had always worked so hard
when in truth
she didn't need to work at all
but of course joan did
need to work
precisely because she did come from her
family
the schoensteins have long believed
and long proven
that working
helping others is necessary and
important
that no one is ever so wealthy that she
can afford not to serve
and joan believed passionately that
independent american journalism
was an excellent means of serving
others
joan kept working even through a long
illness
she discovered that even as her body
grew weak the work
kept her spirit strong
i want to tell you these things because
you may not have known joan shornstein
barone
you may not realize that when the radio
and television correspondents
association chose to call this award
the barone award
they could have given this prize in
recognition of friendship
or courage
or wisdom or grace and dignity or sense
of humor or love of family
or a gentle caring smile or any of those
other qualities joan possessed so
quietly and so abundantly but this award
is not given in recognition of those
things
it is given in recognition
of work
good work
the kind of work that was important to
joan herself
she never stopped striving for
excellence
even after she'd long since achieved it
i said before that i miss her and i do
and i said it's hard to believe that
she's gone
and it is
when i look i see her still and some of
her friends and colleagues and all the
people she loved
i see and her people who never knew her
but who are striving in their own ways
to excel
as joan once did
and i believe i hope
that i see her spirit and those to whom
this award has been given
the judges in presenting the verona
award tonight
have been some outstanding professionals
john bisney
congressional correspondent cnn radio
margie lehrman washington producer for
special coverage and events nbc news
and michelle mcqueen correspondent abc
news
i hope you will welcome them as they
stand
thank you especially for doing that
because let's face it with sporting of
them
to sit on an awards panel named for
somebody who did not work at cnn nbc or
abc
the judges had this to say about their
decision
and i've been asked to read it now
direct quotation
breadth depth
careful reporting of complex ideas as
well as elegant production
it is the kind of work many of us say we
would do if only
if only we had the time if only our
executives would let us if only we
weren't so burdened by the press of
daily events and crash of deadline
a team of producers correspondents
editors and videographers took advantage
of the unique circumstances of last
year's election
where the major candidates were decided
early in the year
to take a close look at some of the most
difficult and complicated public policy
issues
such as immigration and rising wage
inequality
and then they presented them in
beautifully styled production that
recalls the best documentary filmmaking
continuing to quote
from the awards
committee
but we also know that the core of what
we do
is covering the crush of daily news
the best of us find a way to present the
daily story not only with accuracy and
fairness
but also with a measure of style and wit
that is uniquely our own
it is especially noteworthy when that
combination can be found
amid the exhaustion and banality
of a political campaign and that is why
the radio and television correspondents
association
has chosen to honor two winners this
year to recognize the vastly different
but complementary styles of reporting
so we honor cnn correspondent candy
crowley
candy
candy is
candy is awarded this for her
consistently excellent daily deadline
coverage of the 1996 dole campaign
as well we honor cnn's democracy in
america 96 series under the direction of
pam hill and anchored by frank sesno
bernard shaw and judy woodruff
now ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming candy
crowley and pam hill
so
thank you very much
congratulations
wow um
thank you very much first of all i
didn't know joan barone i hope
a little of what we've done uh has to do
with a passion for the truth uh
we try
i
i don't need to tell anyone here that
television is a team event
and
this didn't have to do with me
it had to do with a host of people who
if i started naming i'd leave some of
them out i have to mention in particular
my producer mike roselli nothing i ever
did
happened without michael making it
happen
uh kim siegel another producer on the
road
let me thank cnn for
its full-time
commitment to politics
that gave me the opportunity i have the
hotel bills to prove it was full-time
from tom johnson on down that commitment
was there and it was
wondrous to do it it really was which
will come as a surprise to the people i
complained to on a daily basis but
it was fun
let me just
in particular thank one person
the head of our political unit tom
hannon i wanted to thank him especially
tonight because first of all he gave me
the opportunity to do what was what was
a really fun thing and and second of all
because
when we had a tough call on the road
about
what the
what the lead was or what should or
shouldn't be in a spot
um and i would call tom and i'd say tom
i think it should be this way and he'd
go okay well you're there i trust you
so tom uh
i'll love you forever for that
for the opportunity and for the freedom
i thank you um i i thank the judges very
much this is this is awfully nice
uh and again it's it's a team thing to
the producers and the editors and the
cameramen and the sound techs
and all the people that made this happen
this is yours a lot more than it's mine
thank you very much
in america consisted of uh seven and a
half hours of
uh programming essentially uh news
analysis um hard slogging works and i
think some not sometimes not as exciting
as the daily news
but i'd like to also think that it is it
was the work that in many ways the first
amendment intended
and
for giving us the time to do that for
supporting us in
in in that effort i'd like to say
great thanks to
to ted turner to tom johnson and to uh
and to a wonderful team and that worked
incredibly hard to to make this possible
and i think i'd like to say particular
thanks to a great man in our industry
because he's retiring saying soon john
lane who has
always stood for the best in television
news thank you
okay
thank you dan and congratulations again
to our colleagues at cnn
now it is my honor to introduce the
president of the united states
hmm
thank you
thank you very much
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
members of congress members of the press
fellow sufferers
i would like to thank the radio and
television correspondents association
for inviting me this evening
i want to give terry murphy a special
thanks for the kind introduction and
also given my condition i'd like to give
a special thank you
to the ridgewell catering company for
bringing me here tonight
i uh
enough laughs
i have come here tonight to speak about
a topic of
perennial concern in washington
something we never get around to doing
anything about
and that is the close
some would even say cozy relationship
between the rarified elite
who make public policy
and those who report on it
and on that topic
just let me say this
congratulations andrea
you know that fella standing next to you
in the newspaper photos a few days ago
he looked exactly like alan greenspan
only exuberant
uh
i want all of you to know that
until recently i had
planned out a really
dramatic entrance to this dinner
and then george bush stole my thunder
i mean look at this
this guy is 72 years old
he jumps out of a plane at 12 000 feet
he lands without a scratch
i fall six inches and i'm crippled up
for six months it's ridiculous
now
as you might imagine my injured knee
adds complications to my schedule
in fact you know just when i was on the
way over here tonight
well as you have seen my press secretary
mike mccurry just handed me a note
according to wire reports
former president bush has just bungee
jumped off the seattle space needle
that reminds me i was supposed to make
another announcement tonight
mr murphy has asked me to tell you that
the radio and television correspondents
association
has decided to adopt the practices
of the democratic national committee
that means you can all pick up your one
thousand dollar refund checks on the way
out tonight
you uh
you know i'm getting a little sick of
these fundraising stories
but
here i am i'm doing the best to do the
job the american people sent me here to
do
but with all this ruckus in washington
these days we have to work harder and
harder to sort of be heard through the
den
so my staff worked up a few new ideas
that we thought might break through
i want you to be the judge
after all it's your den
here are the suggestions
take a cue from the tv show ellen
start a rumor that in the last
presidential press conference of the
season
my character will become a libertarian
announce that we discovered signs of
life on mars
we already tried that
and some of you bought it i couldn't
believe it
uh
announce that i will fight evander
holyfield
anytime any place
here's the vice president's suggestion
sign an executive order
hiring people on welfare
to install computers in our nation's
classrooms
to email messages to neighborhood watch
volunteers
to use their cell phones to call a
hundred thousand community police
officers
to remind the one million literacy
tutors
to show up for work
if all else fails
push myself down a flight of stairs
as you know that's the one we decided to
go with
it worked for a while and i'd do it
again
i may have to
thank you very much mike
ladies and gentlemen
you'll be pleased to learn that former
president bush
has just successfully jumped the snake
river canyon on a rocket-powered
motorcycle
now he's just taunting me
you know
one of the results of being bummed up
for a while is that i've gotten to watch
a lot more television than normal and
i spent a day in the hospital just sort
of channel flipping surfing that's what
you call it now
and i was amazed at the way all these
different channels struggle to
accurately but uniquely cover my surgery
c-span of course provided live
uninterrupted coverage of my injured
knee
while c-span 2 devoted full coverage to
my other need
within an hour of the accident cnn had
composed ominous theme music
and put up a graphic
breaking news breaking news
i knew it was going to be a major story
when their headline news
devoted a full five seconds to it
msnbc immediately proclaimed itself
the state-of-the-art global interactive
command center for all leg related news
espn broke into the north carolina
colorado basketball game with a
breathless bulletin
that greg norman was just fine
pbs kept interrupting coverage of my
knee for pledge drives
for every hundred dollar donation you
got a commemorative x-ray of my leg
bob novak went on crossfire to argue the
positive aspects of debilitating knee
injuries for democrats
then there was mtv
all they wanted to know was
did i wear a hospital gown or pajamas
another one
thank you mike
ladies and gentlemen
president bush has just had himself
manacled
placed inside a padlock trunk
and submerged off the coast of
kennebunkport
the clock is ticking
our prayers are with him
anyway
i'm back on my feet
and i'm working for the american people
congress is based in session this week
that came as a surprise to people in
washington who didn't know it was away
things have been so slow this year
c-span's actually showing reruns of the
104th congress
and
we can't get agreement to change the
consumer price index that's the hang up
on this whole budget deal
and there are democrats and republicans
in the house they're scared to death of
it
but you know a small change in the cpi
could shave billions of dollars from the
deficit
add years and years to the life of the
social security trust fund
now i know this is a complicated issue
for some people and i've been looking
for some
simple way to explain it and so consider
how we might re-index some other
statistics
for example a report said last month
that we americans
are the heaviest people in the world
working together
reaching across party lines
we can change all that
instead of 16 ounces to a pound we'll
say there's 20.
that way
a person who weighs 260 pounds would
weigh 106 200 pounds away 160. think
about it
overnight democrats and republicans can
make america the thinnest nation in the
world
let me tell you
i'm doing the best i can but actually
i'm kind of hurting the worst thing
about this injury is it's hard to stand
for long periods of time
and about this time i start to get tired
so i'm going to sort of sit down with a
confession
when i signed that executive order
banning cloning research
it was too late to do anything about an
experiment or two that had already been
started
but one of them has come in handy in
moments like this
bill would you mind
mr president have a seat
by the way i'd uh i'd appreciate it if
you'd refer to me as mr president
i think you've earned it
mr president
members of the house and senate
ladies and gentlemen
as you can see
i'm also bill clinton
typically
when i come in to mop up at
the end of an event like this
i'll just finish reading from some
prepared text and say things like
we must find common ground
we're going to build a bridge to the
21st century
i'll have to refer you to lanny davis on
that one
yadda yadda
mr president mr president
this is odd
evidently uh george bush has
successfully escaped
and has been spotted swimming toward the
coast of maine
hell does that mean
well
where was i
oh yeah you know what i would like to
tell you all about tonight
how much i ha hey
how much i hate
waiting around to see if i'm going to
pinch it for him today
it's demeaning
it's dehumanizing
i don't know how al gore's put up with
it all these years
but i
i shouldn't complain
i mean if you're going to be a clone you
could do you're not going to do a whole
lot better than being a clone
of the president of the united states
the key to being a clone is making sure
you're the clone of somebody cool
let's face it
this gig could be a whole lot worse
imagine waking up and finding out you're
a bob dornan clone
sitting up all night counting votes
it is not for the squeamish
i did get some uh some work done i had a
meeting with
some members of congress about some
chemical weapons
some treaty type thing
mr president uh remind me are we for
that or against it
report
i'll tell you what i do love that red
phone
oh by the way maybe you ought to be the
one to call yeltsin back and apologize
if i call him again i'll just make it
worse
i'll come back up here
mr president of the united states
um
i have to take this over before it gets
out of hand
god knows i can't afford to jeopardize
my relationship with the press corps
but
i want to thank you bill uh
mr president
by the way i wrote up a to-do list for
you for the next couple of days
as usual uh there's the morning jog you
have to do that now
tomorrow at 3 30 i have a conflict
i have a root canal appointment and a
press conference in the east room
i know it's going to hurt but would you
mind doing the press conference
no wait a minute i couldn't ask anybody
else to do that even me
actually i enjoy these press conferences
and i
i enjoy coming here every year
i thank you all for what you've done to
sustain our democracy for nearly 225
years our country is still a work in
progress
and i look forward to building on that
progress with you
i even look forward to these dinners and
i really wouldn't want to send
anyone else in my place
so i want to thank all of you for having
hillary
me
and me here this evening
in closing let me say
we must find common ground
we are going to build that bridge to the
21st century
i do have to refer you to lanny davis on
that one
yada yada good night and thank you very
much
thank you i'm not really sure who to
thank but uh
thank daryl hammond from saturday night
live and thank you again mr president
for coming back
continuing with this saturday night live
theme our next speaker is currently in
his fourth season on that show
he doesn't do an impression of the
president but he does a great impression
of bob dole
andy rooney and charles carlt
recently he ranked number two on rolling
stone's list of the 101 best things
about watching television
and once a week he gets a taste of our
jobs when he anchors that program's
weekend update please join me in
welcoming noor mcdonald
all right i won't be as funny as that
last bit
just so you know you know
well good evening mr president
he's his first lady
and the distinguished members of the
radio and television correspondents
dinner you know when i accepted the
honor of performing here tonight one
thought crossed my mind and that was uh
please god don't let me bomb in front of
the president
but i'm not worried what the hell do i
carry you know i got i worked on all my
jokes i got a lot of help from from my
joke writer don imus he was helped me a
lot
are you familiar
you know this guy he's a funny guy he
wrote some jokes
anyways the dinner was great you enjoy
the dinner we had some salmon that was
delicious it was great and i thought it
was you know i thought it was refreshing
to see democrats serve something other
than subpoenas for a change i thought
that was nice you know
i'll be doing some jokes later i just
thought i'd
oh
but you know it is rather daunting to me
and i'm just a guy you know the hell am
i
and here i am you know i look out i see
president bill clinton you know i see
secretary of state madeleine albright
you know media mogul rupert murdoch you
know broadcast legend larry king you
know
pornographer larry flint
you know
dick morris the list is starting to drop
off a little folks but
still you get the idea it's
daunting
and of course it was very inspiring to
see
president clinton up here on crutches
making a speech i mean i thought that
was just amazing you know
i mean it's been difficult for the
president you know he can't jog now and
he needs help getting around and he's
still
you know he still
occasionally suffers great pain you know
on the upside you got your medical
marijuana so that's uh
you must inhale sir it's the only way
you're gonna get better
it's
but
but it's not i mean i think this is the
first time that i can remember that
we've had a president that has hobbled
you know and uh it's tough on everybody
the secret service is not easy on the
secret service they have had to learn
you know how to uh how to do this and uh
they've been specially trained on how to
lift and carry president clinton by top
experts who've been doing this for a
long time
boris yeltsin's secret service agents
they've
they've stepped in to help you know
anyways
excuse me i'm sorry folks uh larry flint
and dick morris are giving some sort of
hand signals to each other over there i
can't
i don't know what the hell that's all
about but
it's kind of hard to concentrate
larry flint is here tonight
but also present this evening madeleine
albright the secretary of state ms
albright's been very busy you know she
just returned from russia where she
you know applied for
yeah madeleine albright
she's been very busy she just went to
russia where she met with boris yeltsin
you know and they uh they had some talk
on nato expansion i guess they kind of
had a tense meeting you know when ms
albright came back out she said she said
for this i travel five thousand miles to
meet with some drunken meshuganet
on my worst enemy i wouldn't wish this
this is
jesus
changed you know that's what i find
she's
but of course looking around the room i
also see many distinguished members of
the fourth estate uh i see brian gumbel
is here and uh he just signed a
multi-year contract of course with
cbs and uh you know he took some time
off to be with his family after the
today show but but bryant in his heart
you know is a news man and after a few
weeks he realized you know that he
missed the excitement and thrill that
you can only get by making millions and
millions of dollars so
and dan rather of course is here he is a
broadcast legend i love dan rather you
know i uh
i talked to him backstage and it was a
real thrill for him you know and uh he
was just he was so excited to be here
you know i was backstage i've never seen
him so excited at one time at one moment
i remember he broke into a huge frozen
smile and it was
there it is again there it is take a
look
that's the huge frozen smile i'm talking
about
ah we got a lot of power here a lot of
juice mr rue larlage is here of course
the chairman of abc news you know and a
lot of crazy stories coming out of that
division you know
you know stories about this person
sleeping with that person and all that
you know scandal after scandal if you
heard the latest i heard this just the
other day there's a rumor that last week
a certain i don't want to say it is a
certain gentleman in abc news he went to
a party and he got really drunk and he
ended up having sex with his own wife i
don't know
i don't know how these rumors get
started but you know
it's probably just a vicious rumor
really you know
but as mr harlage knows of course tv has
become a very tough game you got to stay
competitive you know
as we all know abc's good morning
america is a little turmoil you know a
little trouble a little rating trouble
and uh they're considering a lot of ways
now you know to uh to boost the ratings
and i don't know i think they're getting
a little desperate i
i heard that next week charles gibson
will announce he's a lesbian i mean is
that
is that going to help anything
nobody wants to hear that
martha stewart is here and she wanted me
to tell you don't let the busboys clear
your table off tonight because a little
later marth will come up here and she's
going to show us how to take those old
discarded fish bones and make a
beautiful birdhouse
so
that's nice
i'm very nervous i don't know why
before i sip this coffee actually sir
how much is this
how much how much would a cup of coffee
cost in a place like this
for you nothing it's free okay great
i didn't want to get you know i didn't
want to see 90 000 on my bill later
i'm sorry
and of course there are some important
uh washington figures who couldn't be
here tonight uh vice president al gore
is not here unfortunately he uh he broke
down they had to leave him in the shop
overnight but uh
they say it'll be all right later
something wrong with the voice boxers i
don't know what it was
house speaker newt gingrich is uh not
here a little while back of course
everybody knows uh that newt pushed
through a lot of budget cuts in the arts
particularly in pbs you know and the
effects are being felt now i i can see
it even as a as a as a layman you know
just watching you know the other day i
watched that show the the frugal gourmet
it changed its name to the cheap bastard
i mean
it's crazy
and senator ted kennedy couldn't be here
i uh you know you know there's a lot of
jokes about ted kennedy but uh i
recently watched an interview it was
very touching you know it was ted was
talking about or mr kennedy what the
hell am i calling him ted for
senator kennedy was uh was talking about
how he how he uh proposed to his lovely
wife vicky reggie and it was it was very
touching you know it was a different
side of ted kennedy that you don't see
he was very old-fashioned or romantic
you know when he made the proposal it
was very nice he got up on one knee and
he
it was nice you know
you hear all the stories but then you
hear something like that you know it
makes you
i'm starting to relax now you know i
think i'm relaxing a little
that's not just the booze talking i
think i really am relaxing
it's the xanax the prozac and the booze
talking
but uh no i'm a little nervous you know
i mean where the hell am i but uh it's
been great to be in washington i can
tell you that man oh my god i i had a
lovely stay here so far i've been
sightseeing you know and in fact i
stopped in a museum this is probably
interesting to you guys they have this
news museum now have you seen this it's
a museum that's dedicated to broadcast
journalism and they have all sorts of
you know tributes to to edward r murrow
and such you know and they have this one
fascinating place it's a kind of an
interactive display and visitors what
they can do is they can appear on camera
and pretend that they are real
journalists you know so far it's been
visited 20 times by matt lauer but uh
i guess he's a legend too i didn't know
yet
murrow severide edwards and lauer
all right
and also today i took a visit to the
white house for any of you haven't taken
a visit to the white house unbelievable
so you know awe inspiring and you know
very loud rich in history so beautiful
you know although i did i noticed a kind
of an odd sign on the president's desk
it said the yen stops here have you seen
it
what the hell's that mean
the yin i thought it was the buck stops
here i'd always heard
uh you know of course they say the white
house is haunted did you know that
and uh i thought this was kind of sad i
heard
last night that president clinton
charged abraham lincoln's ghost ten
thousand to sleep in his own bed
so
that's that doesn't seem right to me you
know i mean
but look the president you know has come
under a lot of fire for raising money
but you know you know he's good at he's
good at raising money that's not a bad
thing every president's done it's just
that president clinton is very very very
good at it
do you know he has organized in the past
year over 100 fundraising dinners and
over 200 fundraising midnight snacks did
you know that
is he laughing
is he
is he
now the president mr president seriously
you know i know you've had to work
through a lot of distractions and doing
the business of running this country and
i i just want to say you know that i
implore you stay focused and do the job
and and try to remember you know that
that rome was not built in a day you
know i mean just ask strom thurman he'll
tell you it's
it was not built in a day of
he's an old fella you know folksy
how would you not know that
oh i have an announcement to read i
almost forgot i was supposed to i was
told to
make this announcement uh table 10
wherever you are table 10 we're sorry
your waitress hasn't been there in a
while
larry king just married her so
oh i have to say though you know this is
an incredible thing for me you know i'm
just a punk you know and yet here i am
you know i can't believe i'm speaking in
a room i'm standing in a room here with
the most powerful man in the country
alan greenspan you know and i
it's a little amazing to me it's a
little you know
of course that's a big story in here in
washington is the
recent marriage between nbc's andrea
mitchell and alan greenspan who is 71
years old and this is sweet you know i
didn't know this they wrote their own
vows you know she uh she promised to
love honor and speak into his good ear
so that was
it's kind of sweet you know
the newlyweds are going to spend their
honeymoon in mexico and i thought this
was sweet
as a gift to his new bride alan
greenspan just devalued the peso so that
they'll
that'll be nice
a little bit more of my coffee
anyways
you know it just occurred to me mr
president you are now handicapped and
you're the president of the united
states you must have an unbelievable
parking spot you know
yes
that's got to be very close to the
building you know
but um
you gotta hand it to the president his
injury is not holding him back from
doing the the business of the nation you
know he in fact he just nominated major
general uh claudia kennedy as the army's
first female three-star general and i
think that's great you know she's doing
a great job apparently the only thing
she's having trouble with she's
she's having difficulty figuring out how
to sexually harass herself she doesn't
know how to
what's that
guy yells my name for no reason
oh i have another announcement to make
is that what you're you're telling me
but i should make this announcement
you're right you may you make a good
point with your incoherent gibberish
here it is
here's my other announcement the u.s
state department folks has just issued a
travel warning for all women moving past
dick morris's table so
i don't know
i don't know well that's about it for me
i just want to uh
how about this heaven gates call this is
what everybody's talking about it's
unbelievable and it really is a sad
story and it's hard to comprehend i mean
think about it who in their right mind
would believe that you get into a
spaceship behind a comet by castrating
yourself and committing suicide i mean
other than pierre salinger who on earth
would believe
i just saw him on the lobby with a pair
of sneakers nike sneakers and big purple
shroud going where are they
like did i miss it
well that's it for me folks i just want
to say you know before
i go that it really has been a thrill
for me i joke around about the news you
know but you people you do the real
thing and uh you serve as our watchdogs
and you tell the real stories that come
out of the city and i for one you know
think you do a darn good job and as a
matter of fact i have a message from
someone who couldn't be here and wanted
me to read it to you this is from uh
from senator bob dole he wanted me to
read this to you
here it is
this is it this is from from senator bob
dole
ladies and gentlemen of the press
to hell with ali you cost me the damn
election
you can kiss my ass every last one of
here
thank you folks thank you very much
thank you very much norm i guess you can
turn to the eye miss program tomorrow
and see how you did
before i turn the chairmanship of this
this association over to vic i'd like to
thank a few people
as you know our job covering capitol
hill is made easier by the staff of the
house and senate radio television
galleries
so join me in thanking tina tate and her
staff beverly braun gail davis ogre
ramirez chris hill and eric leblanc
and on the senate side larry janzik and
his staff jane rule diane lane gloria
halcombe andrew eliason and
mike massrian
thanks
there are over 2 000 people here tonight
you don't have that many guests for
dinner without the efforts of a lot of
people but i'd like to single out just
one individual
ivan goldberg of barbara boggs
associates once again this year has done
a terrific job helping our association
organize this dinner so join me in
thanking ivan i think she's over here
somewhere thanks
ivan and finally there are just a few
people at c-span i'd like to thank for
their help and support first brian lamb
who is probably asleep by now since he's
on there tomorrow morning
but also susan swain rob kennedy barry
katz carolyn for west and of course
kathy murphy thank you all guys
and now it is my pleasure to introduce a
man i've enjoyed working with the last
year the current chairman of the radio
and television correspondents
association from abc news vic ratner
it's been a wonderful evening because
terry murphy worked a year to make it
happen
let's give him a round of applause terry
murphy
thanks for coming
we'll see you next year
please stay in your seats if you would
while the presidential party departs
thank you
oh
oh